la fraude au président une personne se
fait passer pour le chef d'entreprise
pour obtenir des virements et prendre la
trésorerie voilà l'un des sujets abordés
lors des ateliers organisés par la
gendarmerie des yvelines le medef est
hélas ces pme pour les chefs
d'entreprise l'objectif d'inviter les
chefs d'entreprise c'est tout simplement
de les prendre en compte dans une
manoeuvre globale pour les éveiller sur
un certain nombre de sujets et
singulièrement en ce moment puisque
l'activité économique reprend et
également dans un contexte où la cyber
délinquance explose en tout trois
ateliers thématiques la protection
bâtimentaire la lutte contre les fraudes
et la cyber protection pour animer un
binôme constitué d'un gendarme et d'un
chef d'entreprise qui a pu subir déjà
des actes malveillants oui ça nous est
arrivé quand quelque chose vous arrive
vous et de réfléchir à comment je peux
aussi l'utiliser pour le bien des autres
pour pouvoir informer lançant des chefs
d'entreprise qui ont bien souvent notion
de sa va pas m'arriver si les autres non
c'est tout le monde est concerné un
dernier atelier été menées par le gign
pour expliquer comment se comporter en
cas d'atteinte de haute intensité sur
différents sujets comme le risque
d'attentats en tout ce sont une
cinquantaine de chefs d'entreprise qui
ont participé à ces ateliers j'ai appris
notamment comment réduire les risques
informatique on avait fait j'ai fait le
cycle cybersécurité donc l'e mail et
mots de passe changé bien faire
attention aux fichiers bien faire
attention aux liens et tout ça toutes
ces sensibilisations que j'ai entendu
m'a permis de voir que même si je suis
bien organisé il peut y avoir des
failles dans l'entreprise d'autres
ateliers sont prévus dans les mois à
venir et toutes les semaines les
gendarmes se rendent au sein des
entreprises pour voir les problématiques
et tenter d'y répondre